you're delusional
and just like grab
listen
my girl can never come to me and say
stop all that
[Music]
as you already know guys we hit straight
from the source we're going straight to
the question and the question of the day
was what's the worst Valentine's Day
gift slash experience you've ever
received this one's going to be Saucy I
already know obviously obviously
juicy yeah all right gang I'm ready
worst Valentine's gift or experience
Jesus yeah
I was hiding at home as a surprise he
brought another girl home instead
[Laughter]
game is a game yeah that's horrible but
Gamers don't surprise me with nothing
that surprised nowhere expose yourself
yeah yeah so I know what to do next make
yourself no so I know how to respect you
make yourself known so I know my next
move yeah
I know how to respect
s broke up with me the day before so he
didn't have to buy me anything he won me
back four days later because I have no
core strength oh bro oh a hundred
percent
that's
so rookie oh bro I have no core strength
I just need him back that's that's so
important that is flipping poor a set of
PJs that was size 20 and was size 12 to
14 he said it'd be more comfy
so what he's saying is
I know you wear 12 to 14.
but it doesn't look like you should wear
imprints in your skin are telling me
I'm telling you to size oh yeah yeah
yeah I just want you to be comfortable
people relax be honest be honest and be
comfortable in our own yard this is a
safe space it is the same just try it on
just try
I tried to promote my side to my main
promote on Valentine's Day I tried to
promote my side to my main
wow he went he said he's made done yeah
Main's done yeah exciting so let's up
let's do it let's do it Valentine's
let's do a promotion let's do our
Valentine's wow yeah that didn't end
well clearly clearly didn't end well
my missus had IBS on the way back from
our meal she shot in my car
that was George in it
did you send that one
I see her
body oh IBS is long for everyone
long for everyone bro I couldn't handle
that no pun intended
wow
my boyfriend in Primary School handed
out Valentine's Day cards to everyone in
our class
wow bravado just watching her in her
face there you go there you go babes
babes there you go babes yeah come on
come on come on he's like come on Amanda
foreign
this is disgusting and it's it's very
misogynistic okay when I was in year
seven yeah
or year eight okay
I gave all the girls of my year a
ranking system okay
and it worked like Pate on crackers
sometimes your analogies are so wet
I'd say on crackers it worked like a
chicken liver if I say on a cracker yeah
it just Blended yeah text Julie was
fantastic yeah bro I remember random one
time
um I was chilling and then I said like
oh
some girl was chatting to me and I was
like see this is why you're in my top
five
and then she was like I just randomly
said yeah this is why you're in my top
five and she was like sweat yeah wearing
this top five am I and I was like I'm
about middle yeah don't worry about
middle don't worry about it so who the
[__] is the rest and I was like I don't
know if I'm random another good coverage
is that so where am I I was like all
right
it turned into a whole thing the whole
year yeah the whole all the girls in the
whole year this was all coming up to you
queuing up yes I know bringing me
Flapjacks being like where am I yeah
where am I yeah where am I and it's
ranking away I was like hey come on man
this
a flapjack is that yeah yeah couple
might not throwing up hobnobs yeah yeah
yeah yeah
I'm trying to hold a lips
what are you really really how much do
you want that number one spot literally
literally how bad do you want it
lips me
lips how bad you want that roll flips me
I know you'll be there oh yeah it was
hilarious it was crazy bro that would
have caused a frenzy drink yeah so this
whole Valentine's card to everyone
saying
power play Oh facts power Place facts
facts I can imagine
all right running back what's the worst
Valentine's Day gift slash experience
you've ever received
my girlfriend broke up with me because I
didn't have flowers for her when she
woke up
slap just like in the morning
to say you're it's done you don't have
flowers right man my eyes have been open
for four and a half seconds so where's
where are the flowers where are the
Roses where are the Lily you're wasting
the whole day
you think I'm waiting until later for
this I'm still defrosting I promise you
I'll be so grateful that she broke up
with me so I remember watching I
remember watching don't tell the bride
do you remember that show yeah don't
tell the bride wow and homeboy used to
get flowers delivered to his girl or
bring her flowers every Friday since the
day they met or since the day they
started dating every Friday bringing
flowers
whilst they're prepping for the wedding
and that obviously she's moved in with
her mom he's with his boys or whatever
and he's planning the wedding so in this
whole process she just chills okay
um oh yeah of course so the man does the
whole wedding right yeah yeah on Friday
must have come and gone she didn't uh
get any flowers but like panning to my
man he's pulling his hair out trying to
sort this wedding out the wedding's like
tomorrow or something Friday comes and
goes no flowers she was like big man I
don't think you could get it I don't
want to marry him anymore
like where's the flowers oh my God like
I let him do his Ting for five minutes
and man's forgetting like core parts of
our relationship rummy flowers every
Friday he was doubting the whole thing
she was down she was having second
thoughts about the whole thing because
he forgot these flowers on Friday good
meanwhile man hasn't slept in three days
trying to organize this wedding for her
I can never do a show like that ever
ever of course not that's that's just
all my luck yeah normal is dead drove by
her house to pick her up only to see her
getting inside another man's AMG
he had to say AMJ in it stung I stung
him
I pulled it up I pulled up on a surprise
thing on Valentine's Day to watch her
get into a pristine executive vehicle
Black Tower of course it was blacked out
of course it was black Revan on the
drive he's just reading yeah yeah that
was also just puffing on it
yes another man's AMG not okay I'm
outside in the AMG oh it's right outside
baby girl you know me
wow it's Peak put on sexy lingerie for
him he said his back hurts and went
straight to bed he never touched me
yuck painful yeah yeah yeah
a mate of mine sent this girl lettuce
instead of flowers
lettuce
wow I don't even know what he was
thinking he hates her I don't know what
he was thinking he told me he told me to
bake a cake and write Happy Valentine's
Day on his behalf
hahaha
that's mad on his behalf man them or not
first of all madam are not on
Valentine's Day let's just clear the air
down myself included
it's Butters It's so dead it's so fake
it's so
it's just a facade yeah it's [__]
it's such a facade there's no other way
to put it and then the thing is this
jarring about it is there's levels to it
right so if I'm a dog [__] boyfriend
yeah if I ain't [__] all I have to do is
give you a rose of Valentine's Day and
your gas yeah your gas
if I pay your bills
feed you do everything on a daily daily
basis bring you flowers all the time
yeah yeah fantastic I have to go oh yeah
you have to do more and more yeah if I'm
not proposing on Valentine's Day I'm a
waste man there either needs to be
arranged in the drive or I need to be on
my on one knee otherwise what are we
even doing and why are we here why are
we together yeah so Valentine's Day is
such a great day for [__] boyfriends
there you go guys there you go so yeah
just just acknowledge that yeah so yeah
if your man's a good man and he says can
we just chill just say yes just say yes
our day two facts it's our day too it's
hard day too let's just chill God damn
it
so it takes it
that's jokes ah
my story is so long but for shorts my
mum had a dream so I couldn't go out
what
my mom had a dream so I'm gonna go out
she just feared the worst
nah bro
Jesus I received a long text at 8am
saying how ungrateful I was
foreign
I got um I got dumped after he ate the
meal I cooked for him we were together
for four years and had a mortgage
it's just
I've been having four years of this and
I've held my time yeah yeah enough is
enough I'm tired of your lack of
seasoning and I'm tired of you yeah I
just like it's got to the point where
when we make eye contact my teeth great
yeah yeah like you're so annoying to me
like why am I even in here bro like stop
breathe just stop breathing yeah that's
that's mad yeah
he stood me up I kept on messaging him
but he didn't answer later that night
I'd seen that he'd been arrested
wow chaos my baby mum telling me that my
son really isn't mine but some guys from
work
no
no no no no no no no no no no no it's
just some guy from work
no why Valentine's Day for this
for what reason the guilt must have done
her up because he must have done the
most yeah she was like I I can't do this
I literally can't he probably put the
baby in like a little bow tie no and she
was like you know what first of all get
your hands up here get your hands off my
child because he's not yours I need to
confess some guy from work
ah what is happening bro chaos yeah
there's chaos in these streets yeah that
is horrible flowers with the reduced
price stick are still on and a bottle of
washing up liquid
the man said when we're done with this
facade you dare put in a dishwasher wash
up
wash up I'm tired of seeing these salty
specks all over the dishes do it
properly do it properly because this is
what you need oh wow wow
my boyfriend's friend called me the day
after asking if next time I could lower
my voice when me and my boyfriend are
having sex I was a virgin at home all
day because my boyfriend told me he was
busy
why won't you message your boy yeah you
could never snake me like that that's so
sus
why would he do that bro cause I'm not
even entertaining like if my girl said
sweat like if I saw my girl that day and
was like say swear and then show me a
text from one of my boys saying yo big
man sing next time you man they're
[__] like can you keep it down a
little bit Yeah I'm linking you straight
away I wouldn't even entertain with you
say it because the audacity of me trying
to text your girl that that's why would
I
literally you're a snake and it's all on
purpose
I'm ignoring her because the violation
of this bro code is way worse than
whatever you're doing yeah
but whatever hike you're dealing with
trust me I'm dealing with it worse yeah
facts bro code is different yeah that's
for life
you can't violate me like that
I got a couple more I caught him with
his own cousin two days prior he begged
me not to tell his family wow okay
that's serious that's something like
I didn't think I would have that
the mental gymnastics you'd be going
through in that scenario what if you
were the brother if I'm clapping my
cousin yeah yeah yeah and my girl walks
in and it's like well obviously it's
over yeah obviously but yeah but I need
something from you
and it's like I don't think I have my PR
I don't think my pride would let me say
that to her yeah yeah like
yeah I don't think my pride can let me
say like please don't tell my family
yeah yeah also I can't risk the getting
out but we would lock eyes but she
wouldn't know what I'm saying yeah yeah
it's like sorry but also like
I'm strong yeah I'm strong put me in a
corner yeah yeah I don't know what I'm
gonna do yeah I'm not making any threats
don't test me out there yeah I'm not
making the rest but like obviously
health and safety should come above
everything else fat so let's just let me
just leave that there yeah
your own well-being is is more important
than whatever this is this is happening
here [__] mad this cousin stuff happens
very regularly often question how far
removed of a cousin does she have to be
for you for me to smash and how pain how
pain are we talking about she's paying
enough for you to consider smashing up
bro oh okay
um how distant of a cousin yeah
ah
that doesn't think it's nuts for me I
don't to be fair I'm not I don't really
have enough cousins to even know what
distance means
um I don't have any cars I have cousins
but like I have no relationship with it
yeah I don't know any of my cousins
really so I I wouldn't even know where
to begin
um I guess it would have to be like
let me think bro let me you know what
actually let me give it a a proper
consideration so if it was like
it would probably have to be like
my
mom's
maybe like my Nan's cousins
granddaughter
okay yeah that's very far that's a few
Generations yeah yeah that's different
yeah yeah so my nana and her cousin were
already not even that yeah blood-wise
yeah yeah that's not even that and then
so then we've got cousins here and then
we moved down
from there and then we've got another
generation from there that's very far
away it's pretty out there that's even
then I'm thinking about oh look at them
there that's a bit yucky
I don't know I feel like if there's any
blood at all I don't think I can do it
you know any blood at all bro I'm not
sure
yeah that's a bit twisted yeah
yeah it should have to be Lang and even
then I'm not I'm not looking at this
yeah I'm looking at the tree like
if we can still fit on the same piece of
paper good answer yeah I think
I think in this family tree if we can
still if both our names are on the same
piece of paper it's like I'm not doing
it very good answer I like that all
right last but not least
um what's the worst Valentine's Day
experience gift you've ever received a
half-hearted [__] after she spent
most of her day with her Mane
oh really
half-hearted
she was like this is a chore um this is
not what sides are for I'm tired I've
done this four times already today yeah
I woke him up to this
I couldn't hear that yeah wow I can hear
that wow I couldn't hear that
I woke him up to this
right
that would be tough to handle that would
rock me to my core yeah yeah that will
rock me to my core oh wow oh but yeah
that was a question of the day guys oh
God I woke him up to this of course you
did as well but the thing as well like
sides I would never if I'm a if I'm a
girl sighting I'm never Lincoln on
Valentine's Day facts especially at the
end of the day when I know she's been
with her man all day it's just like
respect yourself respect your
relationship a little bit but like I
don't we can do this tomorrow there's
literally any other day yeah because
like and also sides are for as and when
I please
well as when we please you don't need to
fit them into life yeah don't squeeze me
into Valentine's day bro let's just
leave it a half-hearted [__] because
she's been busy today
he just knew he just knew he sat there
like well I'm even here yeah literally
am I even here literally wow it was like
let me just get one in yeah she's yeah
let me guilt trip her over that's
disgraceful
um but anyway welcome guys welcome guys
welcome back thank you so much for
coming back uh on this beautiful Monday
um
bro it's been decent you know it's been
cool
um we've had a great time love you guys
um I'm pretty sure the tour is sold out
now so guys everyone who is coming thank
you so much we are super super super
super excited
um and you know what let me just address
the haters all of you hundreds of people
that DM me moaning that you're gonna get
tickets literally your business you
weren't on job everyone else was on job
yeah everyone else was there at 10 A.M
when they went live bang bang done you
waited four days and then DM me like um
what I sold out you just didn't what you
clearly don't rate US yeah because you
were like the guys thought we wouldn't
sell out so quick let me leave it a week
and I'll just pick up where they left
off no yeah sold out in days yeah a
couple days it was done bro it was done
and that's your business problem but
anyway thank you so much for everyone
that's coming we're really really
looking forward to it it's going to be
sick it's going to be sick relax
um but in the meantime guys what we need
you to do is head on over to patreon.com
shits and gigs and join the humongous
community that we have over there enjoy
three and a half years worth of content
from ourselves from Grassroots up to the
position that we're in today
um
and enjoy join our Discord Community
guys
really invest yourself into the cult
baby culture and uh yeah man it's a Vibe
okay
um right so I forgot it last week I was
so annoyed I actually forgot to do it
last week for the intro the intro the
proper proper intro
um
so I did LS two weeks ago introduced
Ellis to the gang
um that was cool I'm gonna do REM today
okay right so big introduction so for
guys who weren't here two weeks ago when
I did your introduction I'm trying to
give everyone in my life a massive
massive introduction
um and express what they mean to me and
just like who they are as a person and
build excitement around that person and
I think it's important to do that to
everyone that you see and it gives you a
newfound appreciation for the people
that you probably take for quite in
every day right so let's do Ram today so
love that
where do we start with REM right
so REM
I met REM
on our first day oh he stared at me bro
let me speak
it's gonna be good bro all right I'm at
RAM on our first ever day of uni yeah
same name at me same day I met you
um it's not about you so just
okay for a minute
don't put a pin in there
um yeah so first date room first day of
uni yeah and remember's actually the
first one I spoke to out the two of you
because he I was eavesdropping on your
UMass conversation and I heard him say
the word basketball and I was like this
is my chance this is my chance to make a
friend
this is my opportunity to make a friend
yeah I'm not gonna let it slip through
my fingers these are the only black guys
in the entire course and they're talking
basketball so let's chat so I begged it
with you man and um as of then REM
didn't take a beat REM did not waste a
single second into bringing me into his
inner circle literally from the jump
that same day we went and played
basketball
um where he introduced me to Jacob as
well on that same day
um
we in second year we lived together
along with Toby as well
um and that was Sensational in second
year you actually know first of all REM
uh introduced me to his inner circle on
the first day we've ever met was which
was insanely generous he introduced me
to protein shakes and the gym because he
was an 18 year old guy who was rammed
for no reason yes wearing [__] um
wife beaters wife beaters all day every
day wifey isn't a snapback and his
forearms didn't make sense from day one
it's the first thing I noticed the first
day we met I was thinking this guy's
forums are massive you're 18 Brothers
you're 18. you're on steroids and I
remember him saying bro I take protein
shakes and I was like gang and obviously
know nothing about anything I'm like
does it have steroids in it first of all
first question is this steroids in there
yes because if there is it I want to
take it secondly does do they work yeah
yeah same dumb questions work and I was
like well he's Wham yes he must do
something so he introduced me into the
gym life
the first day we went gym together I
remember as well he um we went to
Futures this before we signed up to UNI
gym oh wow first every day we went to
Futures yeah and I'd been gym like three
times in my life and he was like cool
like we're gonna do like a dumbbell
press and I was like say less light and
he was like what weight do you fancy and
I was like I remember I said 15s okay
and I was like that seems light and he
was like yeah I can't literally can't
but this time he was doing like 30s I
was like yeah say this let me just walk
bench flat bench yeah let me warm up
some 15s fam one red pen I went ha and
then my elbows collapsed
it was it was long so he introduced me
to the gym life he introduced me to his
friends he introduced me to everyone
um and bro off the Jump he was literally
the most generous person kindest person
brought me in met his family like super
quick brought me to Birmingham met his
Birmingham friends like like I was
integrated into the REM cycle from like
jump yeah he didn't waste any time
um and the first thing we ever properly
bonded over was me having Naruto
headbands in my in my room yeah yeah
yeah in my room and then we bought it
over anime he was the first ever grown
adult that I else that I knew who
watched anime apart from me and that was
uh that opened my world to a whole new
culture um
and that encouraged me to to watch other
anime and we we had like a massive Bond
over anime and ever since then yeah he's
just gone from strength to strength man
he's also
um been one of the hardest working
people I've ever met actually
um he took on bodybuilding
um When We Were Young I remember we
started watching YouTube content about
bodybuilders and stuff like that and we
just had a love for it and this guy had
a work ethic that I'd never even seen
didn't even think it was possible yeah
we used to train for competitions
together and this guy would wake up
every single morning and do cardio
without failure without fail I'd go once
a week if I'm lucky
that's why I never won
that's why I never wanted to be fat I
won because I didn't mean because I was
lazy bro yeah yeah he never screamed on
his meals I saw this guy eat the
dirtiest [__] I've ever seen a human
being eat I'm pretty sure one time he
mixed sweet potato smashed sweet potato
and rice together it was horrible raw
yeah it was Grim here you'd do anything
to achieve his goals this guy would do
anything to achieve his goals
um
he saved up to he spent six five or six
years saving for a house
um and went through hell and back to get
it done achieved that and straight on to
the next goal uh literally one of the
most honest hard-working
um respectful kind and generous people
I've ever met in my life
um and has confidence in ways that I've
never seen uh and hasn't a this is a has
a unique ability to make friends with
strangers in a way that I've never
witnessed this guy does not experience
social anxiety in the slightest and I've
never seen it happen before
um
so yeah here's a nice introduction for
REM uh guys enjoy him he's he's a real
one
that was a beautiful introduction thank
you thank you
um right and before we continue yeah
I've got to give someone else props okay
I'm gonna give someone else props random
so when we went and did the 90s baby
show yes a few weeks ago yes Tammy was
talking about how he was born at the gym
yes and he wanted to be a little bit
more social and he wants to get into
martial arts so I suggested that he do
Jiu Jitsu
this [__] bailed me like two
days later and said he'd already done it
oh sick yeah he heard me spiel about Jiu
Jitsu for like two minutes and was like
and said on the show okay cool yeah I'll
look into it literally a couple days
later he was like oh yeah I did that
Jujitsu he was sick I was like swear oh
you went to one lesson and he went to
one lesson and just and just and just
did it up and he was like yeah it was
cool and I was like raw bro I was
expecting you just message me in six
months yeah yeah and say what's the name
of that thing yeah yeah yeah he did it
straight away I don't know people that
do stuff like that yeah yeah go went by
himself
sir went by himself to a class and just
did it I don't know people to do stuff
like that really not that quick anyway
so I was like wow so he messaged me and
was like yeah I had fun he called me
actually so yeah I had fun
um
we chatted and he was saying about like
um because they don't do like beginner
classes there's no structure for like
day one oh it's not like curriculum
there was just whatever day you whatever
they're learning on the day you get
there that's the first thing you learn
okay and it just goes from that and then
hopefully in a couple years time you've
got more of a complete understanding of
it so he went in there and he was saying
how there's a lot of stuff it's a
different language so I said to you I
was so impressed by the fact that he did
it straight away that I was like you
know what bro next time you go
tell me where and when or not I'll come
all the way down and I'll do it with you
gang and I'll teach you all the stuff
that he's talking about I'll teach you
what he means and then at least you'll
have a partner that's not like yeah yeah
so he messaged me the other day we're
gonna go next Thursday nice post show
post recording yeah we're gonna I'm
gonna go
um Essex I think his is one
um so not far from here nice and yeah
we're gonna we're gonna go and do it up
that was gas that's gang so I had to
give him his flowers for that one
because I was like wow a couple days bro
don't shout out to me yeah big shout out
to for Tammy um big one anyway you've
got a fun fact stroke quiz or something
yeah I'm gonna ask all of you by the way
um
what do you think in any in any order as
well if you can
um what do you think the five most
widely spoken languages in the world are
five most wildly
wildly widely widely fam yeah five most
widely spoken languages in the world oh
okay gang I'm excited right gonna go for
do I have to do it in order if you can
do it in order you get bonus puts right
I think number one
is gonna be
Mandarin
I'm not giving anything with tc5
all right I'm gonna try my best I'm
gonna go Mandarin Spanish
Mandarin Spanish
English
I wanna say French because of the
African countries okay
and Mandarin Spanish English French and
I'm gonna say
um I'm leaning towards Portuguese
or almost yeah I'm leaning towards
Portuguese or
maybe Dutch okay
um I'm gonna go Portuguese okay cool
nice I like those answers all right
let's say yes
what do you think the five uh most
widely languages I've spoken no uh oh
[__] can I change my masters no not
until they've spoken all right say less
but definitely
um
okay
English
French okay you can only give me three
just guess two bro just guess two more
just think about the languages that
there are
what's one more widely spoken and
take a guess
okay
all right Alice
the same as who yeah
Spanish English yeah
French
yeah
you can go Cantonese as well if you want
I'll just put Cantonese right well I'm
going to change Portuguese to like
Gujarati or something
okay
but your face is making me not think
it's right
yeah there's a few billion Indians
could write your Bengali or whatever the
main language is in India okay I'll just
type India India India the the
colloquialisms of India yeah
right right official answers are yeah
okay
um Let me let me let you know how many
you guys got right each cool
um
at least you got four
huh REM
you got three
you got all five
but let me take the order okay let me
tell you your order then I'll tell you
the order oh yeah yeah yeah
it's the last minute
oh I I love winning stuff you have no
[__] clue I think we all have the
clue yeah sorry gone so James's answer
was Mandarin Spanish English French and
the colloquialism for India yeah yeah
yeah yeah the official answers are
um let me see if you've actually got any
in the right order
um
no you got in order by zero out of five
but okay five actual languages
first is English
interesting 1.5 billion second is
Mandarin 1.1 billion third is Hindi
Hindi is the okay
602 million fourth Spanish yeah yeah 548
million
um fifth French 280 million so you've
got all five just in a different gang
bro gang bro I'm so over the moon about
that thank you for bringing that today
I'm so over the moon thanks so that was
the fun Factor today um okay I'm
surprised about the Spanish one though I
would have thought Spanish would have
been higher because there's a lot of
Spanish-speaking countries
yeah but
that that is true that is like you've
got like
the majority of South America they speak
also speak Portuguese that's why yeah
that's why I said Portuguese first yeah
yeah um but yeah you've got to Lose
Yourself the majority of South America
Spain uh Dominican Republic yep
um
and I'm pretty sure there's some other
ones as well
um yeah you're right there's a lot of
Spanish a lot of the islands speak
Spanish yeah I'm surprised I'm surprised
um French isn't higher in terms of like
the amount it says 208 or something yeah
it's fifth I'm surprised it's not higher
there's better Africans to speak French
in it exactly bear but yeah never mind
that's sick oh well done thank you very
much for that it's all good um Okay cool
so we've got a quick Last of Us recap
yes
um I'm trying to remember what happened
right this one was a little bit so so I
didn't watch this until this morning oh
okay because I've had a busy week okay
right so it's more fresh for you anyway
yeah yeah it was
so I heard I trained with my brother on
like Monday Tuesday
and he asked me about it and I said I
hadn't seen it and he said oh a lot of
people complain because they not
complaining but a lot of people say it's
just like a filler episode
um it's definitely not a filler episode
because [__] happens it obviously does
happen that's Rel relative to the main
storyline so it's not filler episode
um he said it's his favorite episode so
far
I strongly disagree did he explain why
no because he couldn't because I haven't
seen of course of course of course yeah
but I am I'm going to talk to him later
because I don't understand why but again
I don't know if it's something because
he's played the game I don't know if
it's something where he's like oh swear
like yeah he understands a little bit
more about what's going on I thought it
was cool I thought it was cool
um but yeah I don't know what's my
favorite yeah at no point I don't think
enough happened for it to be like my
favorite so far yeah I I still think
um either episode one or last week's
episode of my favorite I think one or
two For Me Above two's banging as well
one or two for me yeah yeah maybe one um
but yeah I don't really have too much
yeah not much happening
um they want they went on walkabouts for
time
um and then they
um infiltrated this this area that's got
a bag of humans in that that's really it
but obviously a lot happened well I say
a lot happened the climax of it was then
waking up to some brothers with guns in
their faces yeah
this little superhero you yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah
on his face
um but yeah that was it really nothing
much happened but it's one of those
episodes where I felt like because
episodes one two and three were such
they gave them intense it gave us a lot
I felt like this episode maybe
um this week or next week's episode as
well might be a little bit timer before
it gears up yeah there has to be yeah it
can't be high octane all the time nine
episode it can't be no no it just
couldn't be cool it couldn't be all
right say less right right people let's
take a little break to keep the lights
on for us over here guys are you ready
to make some New Year's resolutions that
you can actually keep because our
friends over at marsgate have one for
you it's called a proper a hygiene guys
proper hygiene
the lead isn't below the waist grooming
and Experts of men's hair removal have
you covered for your much needed
resolution of feeling your best and all
you need to do is join the 7 million men
worldwide who trust manscaped with our
exclusive offer if you're new to the
gang here it comes it's manscaped.com
and whilst you're there use the code s n
g that's Sierra November Golf and then
with that you're going to get 20 off
plus free shipping worldwide guys it is
time to level up and fully align your
hygiene routine with the most stylish
and premium grooming products out there
thank you for listening let's get back
to the shenanigans so that's a little
quick last thing there's not really much
to say to say this
um but there's two things I want to talk
about okay hit me two things I want to
talk about that flipping juicy okay and
it's all right cool first of all
um
slightly jarring
when by the time this comes out this
would have already happened okay UFC
this weekend okay
who's on the card so what day because I
want to watch Saturday I think Saturday
night I think no it's in Australia so I
don't really need to check okay it's in
Australia I know that okay
Islam okay versus my boy Alexander
volkanowski okay I've said that name on
here a few times I don't know the first
brother but we said the other writer
before so talk about so Alex volkanowski
is the guy that I said had that crazy
fight with Brian Ortega okay and nearly
got choked out like twice and just held
on yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah bro so basically Islam
makachev is the lightweight champion at
the minute okay he won it
um who the hell did he beat to get it he
beat someone not long ago but uh who did
he be was he uh
I can't remember who beat you know I
can't remember who he beat to get the
title but anyway he got the title a
little while ago oh my God he beat
um the Brazilian flipping
uh
um
I can't remember his name anyway he beat
um I'm really annoying I can't remember
his name I can tell it's Charming he
beat uh flip in
sick Brazilian
um Charles Oliveira he beat Charles
Oliveira to get the title Charles Rivera
was on like a flipping 15 win streak
okay
um and he was killing it as a champion
he was doing really really well um
lightweight
um one
55 or 65. okay I can't remember
um but yeah
beat Charles Oliveira
decidingly so
um and Islam has had like a big hype
around him because he's excellent but
he's also trained by khabib okay and
khabib says that he's better than him
okay yeah they were both trained by
khabib's dad khabib's dad died after
khabibs that died khabib was like I'm
gonna fight one more time and I'm
retiring if my dad's not here I'm not on
it um because he's retired as like
renowned as like one of the greatest to
ever do it never lost
um
Islam has uh come in and has just wiped
everyone that he's fought oh wow um and
uh khabib again says like this guy's
better than me like he's he's not only
going to be the champion which he is now
he's going to be like
like multiple Weight Champion he's gonna
[__] everyone up like good luck it's
basically what could be saying good luck
okay
he won the title and then called out
um Alex volklowsky who I think fights at
the lower one
um maybe 145 so he wants my mind to come
up move up wait oh he's gonna so they're
gonna they're both but they're both
considered pound for pound best okay
Alex's powerful pound number one I think
Islam's pound profile number two okay so
this is a [__] fight okay both
pound-for-pound contenders bro yeah yeah
yeah they're going after it okay in
Australia Alex um Alex is from Australia
okay they're going after it this weekend
on Australia okay bro so for context
like uh Islam fights very much like
Habib he'll wrestle you if he wrestles
you to the ground you're not getting up
that's a fact okay if he gets you on the
floor good luck getting up
um
whatever you can try all you want it's
not really going to happen
um you might as well just lose that
don't waste time learning how to wrestle
to wrestle him yeah yeah yeah it's like
saying like ah I'm gonna play
how to explain it
it's like
oh I'm gonna play flipping football I'm
gonna play one-on-one football with
flipping Messi he's quick with his feet
so I need to learn this style of Defense
it's like yeah it doesn't matter what
you like do what you're good at just be
better at what you're good at it's the
only way you're going to beat him yeah
don't bother trying to beat him at his
game because he'll destroy you make
sense he's the greatest of all time he's
going to destroy you that's what is
someone do so if you waste time learning
wrestling you're wasting precious
minutes that you could be sharpening the
tools that you already have yeah yeah so
I hope Alex isn't wasting time with his
wrestling thing because it's not gonna
help okay whatever he learns is not
going to have a good wrestler he's okay
okay he's not renowned for it what's his
he's he's an interesting one because
he's one of the ones who's so highly
regarded but he's not a specialist
really in anything okay he's just he's
short as hell
but he's like okay at wrestling good at
striking he's good at striking okay but
he's fast and strong okay so he's one
that doesn't have a martial arts
specialty per se but he's he used to I'm
pretty sure he used to play professional
rugby before he's a fighter okay he's
fast and he's strong and he's got
something that neither of you us have
stamina that boy has cardio on him okay
mad cardio and he every time he fights
he's better than who he was before
and brother okay if he starts connecting
his knuckles to your head he won't miss
okay what he will start teeing off on
your head it doesn't matter what what
yeah in fact he'll just keep throwing
and everyone's landing on your forehead
it doesn't make sense okay and then as
you're like what's going on he'll
[__] smash your ribs with his leg you
don't know what day it is oh God so it's
gonna be a fight it's going to be a
fight and I'm very very excited for it
so um I'm gonna actually say I reckon uh
microchip is going to beat him I don't
want microchip to beat him but I think
he will and I think Alex is having to
come up and wait for this fight okay so
I
um
but they're both putting their best
thing they're both putting their belts
on the line oh okay so whoever wins this
is going to be a two division champ okay
it's gonna be juicy from the main card
oh yeah okay oh yeah the two pound per
pound best in the entire organization
fighting yes
um so yeah that's the main fight I don't
even know who else I don't care okay I
need to see it it's going to be a fight
bro I mean remind me to watch because I
actually want to watch it yeah and the
good thing about it is I heard someone
else say this and I strongly agree the
reason even though I think Alex is going
to be the underdog in this one the
reason people are very excited is
because when it comes to people like
khabib like Islam that are so amazing at
wrestling or so amazing at this thing a
lot of people go in very timid to fight
these guys okay because they just think
don't get taken down don't get take it
down don't get it and it [__] their
game up whereas vulcanowski the kind of
person he is you think he gives the
impression that he's the one of the only
people that could fight Islam and
genuinely truly believe he's gonna win
and that means everything okay
confidence against these guys means
everything because like you just need to
stay on your game yeah
just because they're amazing wrestlers
doesn't mean they're not human yeah yep
yep stay on your game bro
ping his nose off yeah like he can't
like his wrestling means nothing if
you're destroying his face yeah facts if
his nose is gushing he's gotta have to
do something yeah close his eyes yeah
yeah yeah yeah and like make him afraid
to come in on you and then it's it's
calm makes sense but yeah so vodkanos is
one of the only guys that you can think
mentally he can go in there and like
I've already won this so it's whatever
whereas most guys you see with all the
khabib fights everyone who fought khabib
came in there not knowing what was going
to happen um so mentally they already
meant off he had everyone mentally
before
um before anything damn it was a power
Playboy it's everything bro it's
everything I'm excited the UFC for the
next couple months when are we going is
it March March if we haven't been robbed
yeah yeah yeah yeah if we haven't been
robbed yeah yeah we're going in March
um
so yeah I'm I'm gonna I'll I promise you
I'll cry if the whole thing was a scam
she's probably listening right now yeah
the whole thing was a scam I will cry my
eyes out because then it'll be too late
to even get tickets yeah factual factual
but anyway yeah so we're going in March
for that
um Usman uh Edwards rematch Jesus Christ
O2 yeah O2 yeah yeah it's gonna be sick
and uh before that so obviously this
weekend or by the time this comes out it
would have just happened
um
vulcanovsky versus marketev then in a
couple weeks
um we've got
um John Jones versus Cyril gone oh I
finally got the scoop on why Francis
isn't in the UFC anymore as well oh yeah
yeah he's really sad YouTube video about
it okay and it was to be fair it wasn't
really anything it was just negotiations
broke down basically okay he he wasn't
getting what he is worth okay
um at the time of this release the was
he still Champion or no yeah so he was
um he's had a thing with his contract
for a while so I don't know if Cyril
gone how long Cyril gone's been the
interim champ
um but yeah the main fight was always
supposed to be Jon Jones versus uh
Francis and gani Francis is out of the
UFC now he's saying he said like I'm not
saying I'll never go back but basically
he needs to be paid what he's worth uh
so he gave up his belt yeah so when
you're yeah so if you're not fighting
you basically what happens in the UFC is
if you're a champion
if you're a champion and you decide not
to fight yeah
um you vacate your title yeah and then
two random us will fight or the next top
two people will fight each other okay
for the what they call the interim belt
okay and then you need to come in
challenge the new champ and get your
belt back okay but no one wants to be
the interim Champion everyone wants to
always beat the champ that's why if you
get your belt taken because of like
non-participation you'll always get
first dibs to get your belt back okay
because no one wants to be interim
interim because you never beat anyone
you never beat the Champs to get yes
it's not someone's substantial enough to
me yeah yeah you beat the number two guy
or whatever to be number one it doesn't
make sense so um
but yeah so Francis has been out of it
for a bit but now he's officially
obviously officially and because he also
wanted to fight Tyson Fury and boxing oh
because it's big money
not surprised and um Francis has a
record there's a lot of hyper running
because Francis has like the strongest
punch in UFC history
oh because they've got like a punch in
like machine thing okay
and I'm pretty sure his is something
like getting hit by some they said
something like this is obviously
[__] but it's not the power that he
generates when he hit that is apparently
like getting hit by a Ford Fiesta like
40 miles an hour stop it yeah
stop all of that but I think this is
always like I don't believe it but I've
also seen what he does to grown men
a Ford Fiesta at 40 miles an hour fast
stop it I'm just saying what that man
said in it this is my love together and
they love to guess it but I'm not gonna
lie I've seen what he does to people's
Consciousness with one punch bro it
doesn't make sense he's a huge
[__] so him and Jon Jones is
always going to be the sick sick fight
because like no matter what even though
Jon Jones is way more talented than him
yeah and then like literally the
greatest UFC fighter of all time all it
takes is one punch from Francis and
he'll turn your lights off fair enough
so that was always going to be the fight
he's fighting still gone still gone's a
decent fighter he's still gonna be sick
but he's in a couple weeks this is in
like three weeks I think it's beginning
of March okay
um
it's going to be amazing because it's
John Jones's first heavyweight fight
every time like I said I've said to you
before when there are matches you need
to let me know so I can watch them
because I know you like to do debriefs
and I want to be involved I'm just just
here like cool well by the time this
comes out it would have been two days
ago but it's happened at the weekend but
um yeah we'll watch it but obviously not
together but yeah we'll watch it
um right so that's number one done UFC
is number one number two I've got film
recommendation for you I'm excited I've
got a film recommendation I've not seen
it oh I know you haven't seen because it
just came out
on their ear no in the cinema
is it possibly yes it is
you man are sleeping on Puss in Boots
The Last Wish
bro okay with the title as well booster
boosts the last wish my guy oh my thanks
bro some movie it's a movie I love that
oh bro so they've done it in the style
of um animation style of this is how I
knew it was gonna be sick because it's
the same animation style of uh
Spider-Man like into the spider-verse I
would not expect that yeah I've never
seen the trailer yeah yeah I wouldn't
have expected that okay it's a movie bro
okay okay so
um
the basic premise of the movie is it
follows Puss and Boots and he's on the
last of his nine lives
sick okay interesting I mean
already he's on the last of his mind
yeah yeah he's on the last of his top
nine lives and now he's turned from
being the bravest hero of all time
um to
um this guy who's acknowledging his
mortality bro there's layers to this
movie it's a man it's like a it's almost
like a common of Age movie of a guy in
his teens and 20s who thinks he's
Invincible does what he wants before
he's faced with that Achilles heel yeah
okay and realizes that I can I can die
whenever I've been taking risks I ain't
[__] but I ain't strapped up in months
you know what I mean I've been taking
risks out here yeah yeah I need to
protect myself yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
and then in order to protect himself he
loses himself in order in turning into
this person he loses his own sense of
identity oh wow which just spirals into
this depression oh what this is
animation well I'm telling you put some
music
don't say the last list it's a real
movie
so bro this yeah this this pussycat is
faced with the mortality and he's losing
himself in order to protect himself and
it's one of those ones was like
by savoring this last life I'm like also
metaphorically killing myself I have to
kill myself so that I can live yeah and
that's the dichotomy that he's going
through in this movie bro in order to
live I need to die basically and the
realize and the the fear that the real
fear is also exasperated by this bouncy
Hunter who's played by the big bad wolf
who's after him I remember you saying
villain yeah I remember you saying the
Taps his figure well like I said he
gives him the first time they meet is in
a bar puss is on a high bro yeah and
he's just he's just uh not to spoil it
he's just realized he's on the last life
so this is before he really starts to
take it serious first stage is denial
you know what I'm saying it's what I'm
saying grief bro they wrap it all in one
first stage is denial so
um yeah he uh gives him his wanted
process I'm a big fan of yours is that
safe safe he gives it I need your
autograph he gives him the wanted poster
and says bring him in dead or alive he
starts tap in that dead and says sign
right here my guy and he Zooms in he
Zooms in dead dead dead yeah and puss is
like swear so you run it just because he
yeah he said sweat you're on it he said
bro
I've been in here for a while like in
this bounty hunting game for a while no
one's ever escaped me
okay found a big bad wolf is dangerous
dangerous yeah and he has this weird
little calling card thing that he just
does this whistle so like when he's
approaching he's like
so it's like Eerie Eerie as [__] Eerie
say less so you could just be chilling
[__] could just be minding his business
at any point in the movie bro getting on
with some [__] and then out of nowhere
all you hear is
[Music]
that's very and his hairs prick up
okay it's a movie okay it's a movie say
less because how many are there
put some boots yeah I think this might
be the third I don't think I've seen it
have I seen any I may have seen one it's
the second or the third
let me actually have a look because I'm
pretty sure
um I could be wrong
but I'm pretty sure the
the main actor is he an English better
the main actor no no no no no
I'm talking so there's a guy obviously
Antonio Brown but there's a guy that um
chair who knows and he's he kept on
reposting these guys um person because
he's in the movie but I didn't know what
character he played oh look um this
brother
oh okay who does he say he plays baby
bear I was so Random I was about to say
I bet he plays baby bear yeah he's got
like a almost like a James corden-ish
voice okay uh it's interesting yeah yeah
because baby bear literally sounds like
a black James quarter so the fact that
you showed me that I was thinking I bet
he plays baby bear okay
um but yeah I've I've definitely not
seen
um any trailers or anything I've
definitely not seen any other Traders
but I'm trying to see well what put some
boost movies yeah yeah I'm trying to see
what their names are uh so Puss in Boots
Last Wish is the last one obviously
there's supposed to beats one and then
there's
I think that's it
I think that's it yeah oh so nice but
yeah I'm intrigued bro everyone to see
this movie Yes gang and there's no down
time the pacing one thing I will say
pace is perfect okay it's not that long
the pacing is perfect I've definitely
seen Puss in Boots I've definitely seen
the first one calm yeah yeah so that's
my recommendation of this week doesn't
boost the last wish my guy is Pang say
less is Peng I love a good animation
movie who doesn't to be fair yeah also
random um thing is coming aside you do
you remember inside out the Pixar movie
of course yeah you love that movie
yeah yeah
um their new one is coming out called
the Elementals something like that I saw
the post that's coming out this year oh
yeah it's a part two of it it's called
the Elementals yeah should be good part
two of inside out is called the
Elementals like that yeah damn I could
be wrong but I remember seeing the
trailer um the poster it looked like I
said elements I think quantumania comes
out soon as well quantity comes out the
birthday I'll swear yeah all right cool
I'm gonna check that out uh tick tock's
been blowing up about Kang boy I'm not
surprised yeah it's gonna be a villain
yeah yeah he is he is he is all right
say less
um gag all right you've got a question
for me yeah yeah let me just pull it up
would you rather I'll ask all of you as
well by the way and in the comments as
well
we're gonna get some mics and cameras
yeah yeah in the comments as well what
would you do would you rather catch your
partner cheating on you
or
she lose in a physical fight that she
instigated
funny that's really funny because
obviously at the end of both of those
scenarios she won't be my partner
anymore but yeah what can my chest
handle yeah
um
I think the latter yeah as disgusting as
it would be to watch I'd be more
disgusted at that one yeah then that's
horrible
that she started she instigated a fight
and she go beat the [__] up clean she
got cleaned up
um or walking in her just getting
clapped yeah I can't I actually can't
see the first one
I'd gouge my eyes out
um but the second one you can't help her
in a second over like you're you're oh
yeah yeah I think the second one I would
just vomit on the floor and like just
dump her
oh
you're starting a beef and just get
smacked up and left there what's wrong
with you because like girls starting
fights to me is already there but
ugliest thing I can even yeah comprehend
yeah and then get smacked up
nah bro we can't be together we actually
can't but at least on that one it's on
my terms
the breakup is on my terms on the second
one and the first one
I didn't ask for any of this true and
I'm hurting and like you're hurting
differently biologically I just want you
to want me back yeah you know what I
mean yeah I love you with all my heart
and why are you doing this
um so it has to be the second one okay
REM
second
say less Alice
I knew you were gonna [__] say this
really I knew you were gonna say the
first you'd rather watch your girl get
banged like physically than actually
watch her get knocked out
yeah but you walk in on her getting
banged so you see like at least two or
three Strokes
I don't think you'd walk straight back
up yeah well I think you think you'd
walk straight back up I don't think you
walk straight back up
yeah
no but I don't think it's one of them
ones where because it's a it's such a
shock factor I don't think walking out
would be my first
initial thing to do yeah because this is
it's not like I'm working on two
strangers yeah I would walk out then
you're polite as [__] like this is my
girl we're talking about she's getting
her ass is in the air yeah she's getting
absolutely clapped I'm not walking out
brother yeah I can't walk out of that
yeah I can't because I'm just giving
them free rent to continue that yeah
they don't even know you know I was in
there
oh they look they looked back and just
heard the door closer like yeah let's
continue yeah yeah I couldn't walk out
of that brother I couldn't walk out of
that
still is still the first say last the
second one is horrible
yeah say less bro I couldn't do the
first yeah I couldn't handle the first
I couldn't handle first yeah that would
kill me man
and it was stink in there as well it was
stinking there nasty in your yard yeah
my own bedroom no stink of another man
no no but just squelching away but also
watching my girl's hair just getting
dragged on road just
on the floor and she's screaming help
and then to the point where the girl
gives her one stops no
on the side to trip her up I would beg
them yeah for that final KO Bank she's
our stop stop stop
stop uncle uncle please bro please no
more I can't handle anymore nah
embarrassing yeah the most humiliating
experience but the first one's not even
humiliating it's just death I couldn't
see that yeah I couldn't physically
contain that yeah I couldn't so when
Ellis when you when you pop your head in
and walk out
do you make it down the stairs in one
piece
or do you like yeah
my wife got weight loss surgery and she
thinks she's fine enough to divorce me
huh I told her to calm down
men don't want to see her skin hanging
everywhere like melted stick of butter
she's moved on with our male friend I've
got hoes too but why does she do this to
me
help why does she do this like
continuing like come back
my wife got weight loss surgery she
thinks she's fine enough to leave me
divorce me I told her to come calm down
that men don't want to see her skin
hanging everywhere like a melted stick
of butter
that's the peakest thing I've ever heard
that's the biggest analogy I've ever
heard she moved in with our friend our
male friend I've got hers too but why
they do this to me
so she got the surgery I'm assuming
she's got that skin Ting it was probably
that like gastric band yeah it must yeah
a little gastric Banting lost bare
weight and she's like ah actually pay
I'm looking at myself and then we're
like wrong like wow I'm actually paying
like why am I with you why am I with
actually facts why is someone that looks
like me with someone that looks like you
facts and he said you're delusional
and just like grabbed
listen
my girl can never come to me and say
stop all of that who do you think you
want to squeeze my belly
all right bro
I'm laying and you're just like what's
going on just tummy Tom a man said look
at your skin big man
look at your melted bar yeah you look
like melted butter calm down literally
calmed up I'm willing to tolerate it
yeah but please chill out and she's like
I literally want a divorce at this point
that's all I want because I there's
Talent out there for me I need to start
cleaning up yeah because my last few
years that I've been with you have been
so depressing now look at me yeah now
I'm nice I'm of a caliber where I don't
need to deal with this I'm nice and he
said no one wants you and then his boy
was like
I want to check please
mum raised his hand in the corner like
man I'll take you I'm not gonna lie yeah
that Skin's looking a bit yummy I'm not
gonna lie and she said see I like melted
butter I said who doesn't like a bit of
melted butter doesn't like melted butter
wow and he said like I said I've got
I've got hoes too like big man I've been
having hoes I've been having a book
that's what we want to do yeah we can do
it but you're moving in with next man
stop our friend stop it come home
because I've been having [__] but you
didn't know that you didn't know the
things I don't rub that in your face
I don't Rob that in your face I respect
yeah because I know how to run a
household
you're moving crazy oh you've seen one
site of light and you're running wild
yes stop wild literally yeah wow that's
Peak
I don't know how we can help him with
that
he has to let her go oh it's gone it's
done she's already made her choice in
the fact that she feels better she looks
better she doesn't want you yeah she's
made her choice yeah yeah he my only
advice would be like
hit the gym hard yeah hard dedicate your
life to it now on a Remington yeah yeah
dedicate your life the way REM yeah Gone
full circle yeah yeah what a Good
callback yeah um yeah
dedicate your existence to the gym yeah
give it six months for her to be like oh
no we're on the same level now don't
don't post anything yeah ghost on
Instagram for six straight months and
just come back like
um one of them tick tocks was like
Barrel you know what let's feel shake it
yeah yeah yeah exactly exactly she's
like raw her eyes would fall out of her
sock and she'd be like well we're both
tens now and he would be like that's
hilarious you look disgusting the thing
is her DM won't even reach me yeah
yeah yeah
I'm not gonna pay I need to see the deal
I need that gratification that
gratification yeah I'm not strongly
I need a reason to keep going
because boy yeah I need to know it's
hurting her yeah it has to it has to and
it's probably one of those ones where
because she's not after she moved in
with our male friend my enemy now I've
um they still live in the same area they
don't know where I've moved to but I'm a
comeback I'm gonna Bop into that same
Supermarket you might go to every Friday
I'm gonna walk past you yeah email will
see you'll see what I'm dealing with am
I trying to see what a real man like my
cart's full of organic food
you've ever wanted
um cucumbers from free Rings bear chia
seeds now look at me look at is it now
look at my box and look at me yeah I'm
length I'm because you're different you
let a doctor do his thing and you
thought you were like I'm oh natural and
I'm actually I made this yeah I created
this with my own hand look how dusty my
hands are look at the calluses
yeah and keep walking I'll tap them back
on and keep walking yeah right yeah
that's the only advice I could say give
your everything to the gym and keep your
[__] on the side as well and just
like this is what this is what life
could have been like for you if you kept
your mouth shut
I was happy with our situation yeah but
you couldn't help yourself yeah it is
all right anyway guys that's our episode
for today thank you so much for hanging
with us and this was fun and um yeah man
we'll catch you on the next one
[Music]
foreign